I'm sure you've heard the news winter
doesn't have to mean the end of your
garden it's time to build a DIY Cold
Frame this simple project uses wood and
plastic sheeting to create a Cozy home
for your plants and guess what you'll be
enjoying Fresh Veggies even when it's
freezing outside First grab some Lumber
and build a basic frame think of it like
a tiny Greenhouse then cover it with
plastic sheeting to trap in the warmth
easy right place it over your garden
beds and say hello to Fresh greens all
winter long kale spinach carrots you
name name it no more waiting for spring
with your new Cold Frame you can extend
your Harvest and keep those delicious
veggies coming so what are you waiting
for get building and keep your garden
growing thanks for watching don't forget
to like And subscribe for more gardening
tips Stay Green my friends